Things have gone great.
Haven't you heard?
Kansas City is free.
He told me to forgive.
But where is the justice that
buries Henry now?
It ends the way it ends.
Welcome back, everyone.
It's Charlie.
This will be my last of us. Episode
five Trailer Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references. We'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel.
I'm doing videos for all the episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also doing a giveaway
for HBO Max subscriptions.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moment
from the trailer on the video
and everyone is excited to see that bloat
or get out at the worst possible moment.
Like just as things are going crazy,
like a ticking time bomb,
a ticking time blow to the big news.
As per the trailer, Episode
five is being released early on Friday.
Because the Super Bowl is this weekend.
I'll be posting my video right
after the episode actually airs on Friday.
I'll be doing videos
for all the big Super Bowl trailers, too.
This week is supposed to be like
trailer fest.
There'll be a bunch of big Marvel
trailers, a bunch of big DC movie
trailers, Ant-Man, the last Quantumania,
new Guardians of the Galaxy three trailer,
maybe a trailer for The Marvels,
a flash trailer, maybe a few surprises.
I believe Episode five is meant to be
the conclusion of the Hunters
arc here in Kansas City,
along with Henry and Sam from the Games.
We only got a teaser for them
at the end of episode four.
They say the introductions
in their team up for episode five.
They also confirm all of our theories
about
what was shifting
beneath the collapsed floor
in the underground room
that Kathleen didn't want to worry about.
Let's not tell everyone else
because HBO wanted it
to be a huge surprise
when it escapes during episode five,
they did make a couple of changes
from the games for this part
with the blunder.
I'll explain in a second.
But the actual episode title
is Endure and Survive,
which is actually a quote taken
from the video game that Ellie has.
The actual quote
in the context of the Last of US
game is from Ellie's comic book
that she reads during the car ride.
That scene car ride in episode
four on the way to Pittsburgh
in the game on the show, it's Kansas
City here when they're facing the hunters.
Okay.
I know it doesn't look like it,
but this here is not a bad read.
Only one problem right there.
To be continued.
Hey, cliffhangers, where did you get that?
Thank you, Bills.
The comic book is called Savage Starlight
and she talks
about the plot of the comic book with Joel
and how dissatisfied she is
with the ending.
Because things and badly
the comic is meant
to be a big metaphor for Joel and Ellie's
journey just in general.
The full quote is to the edge
of the universe and back in during survive
in the characters, in the comic speak it
after a big battle, Ellie remembers
the quote after one of their big battles
with the hunters
during survive excuse me,
Savage Starlight,
the comic
I've been reading
since the hero says after a big battle.
So the way their battles in the Pittsburgh
part of the game
with the Hunters Planet,
it's a little bit different things.
We've added a bunch of stuff
for the TV show version,
but you kind of see the way
they're using this
because so much of the show uses lines
from the games, moments from the games.
During the episode,
Ellie will probably speak the line
at some point after one of their battles
with the hunters.
The meaning of the quote
is basically that life can be hard.
Sometimes it can feel overwhelming.
This is when you have to grit your teeth
and just power through it.
You can't give up.
So it's Ellie's way of telling herself
to toughen up and telling Joel
does like giving him a pep
talk, basically,
that they'll get through this craziness
with the hunters.
And it's meant to be a mirror for what
Joel told her in episode four after their
first encounter with the hunters
when he said, We'll get through this.
The difference this time is that it's
Ellie being the one to give Joel the pep
talk, as opposed to Joel
trying to make her feel better,
which normally you would expect.
You would expect the adult
to give the pep talk to the child.
But it's another way
The Last of US is showing you
how Ellie is toughening up
and learning how to handle things
as they continue to get worse and worse
for them in the apocalypse.
Learning to survive,
learning to abide at all.
That's part of living in the apocalypse
in the Last of US.
The whole idea that you need
to just learn to deal with this.
But just starting at the beginning
of the trailer footage
of the Kathleen VOICEOVER
talking about the current state of things
in Kansas City and how things have gone
well since the Hunters overthrew Phaedra,
took control of the city.
But it's meant to be ironic.
Like she's sarcastic.
Kelly
Talking about how amazing things are now,
It seems like she's talking to
a bunch of hunters inside this caged area.
Normally,
I would think that they were people
the hundreds were holding in prison
because it looks kind of
like a makeshift prison.
But the cage could just be
a defensive measure against the infected
or an old holding cell
that Phaedra used in The Hunters
are just now using for their meeting.
This scene during the day
with a bunch of hunters
rolling out in their cars
seems like it's happening in present day,
just continuing their search
for Henry, Sam and now Joel and Ellie,
because Kathleen, I think, believes
that they're mercenaries.
Henry called to protect them,
even though it seemed like
she was kind of lying herself.
Like there's no way a little kid
called a bunch of mercenaries
and a couple protect them.
But the whole idea is
that she's bent on revenge
against Henry for the death of her brother
and using the hunters to get it.
Like that's all she cares about,
much to the detriment of everything else
that they potentially have to deal with.
The hunters have to deal with.
It seems like
as they were looking at the blotter
in the basement, just shifting beneath
that collapsed floor, somehow
this is less important than me
hunting down a common teenager
and a little boy, his little brother,
who clearly don't care about us
and are just trying to stay safe.
We should focus on them
and not on all these infected
that are probably going
to burst out and hurt everybody there.
Scenes of hunters rioting in the streets
with fire all over the place.
This is probably from flashbacks to when
the hunters overthrew the Fed authority.
It seems that the idea here is total
chaos, and Kathleen's sarcastic
voiceover mockingly
saying how things are great
because they're free,
but things definitely do not look great.
We see more scenes of them
overthrowing Federal with the hunters
that same night, beating the crap
out of the federal soldiers,
like holding them captive
and just enjoying torturing them.
The hunters in general
are meant to be like a more hardcore,
darker version of the fireflies,
like an opposing authority
to Phaedra, one of the other major
factions on the show.
Like, typically you just think of
the Fireflies versus Phaedra.
But the hunters are meant to be like
that third faction.
And then beneath them
there are many roving bands of rogues
just trying to live on their own
outside of the quarantine zones,
the ones that Joel warned about in the
woods, like, Oh, there are people out here
that might find us.
They have way worse for us plan
than just trying to steal our stuff.
They'll probably try to eat us.
They'll probably kill us.
That actually be us getting off lightly.
And they want to use a lot of these scenes
to show you the people can be even worse
than the infected sometimes.
Like, that was part of Joel's
whole voiceover dialog.
People are just as bad,
if not worse, than the infected,
because we barely saw
any infected during episode four.
But you saw a whole bunch
of really terrible people.
The way you can tell
some of these scenes are in present
day is is just a way fewer trucks,
in a way fewer people
congregating with fewer hunters
standing together.
This is a new scene of Henry
and Sam using sign language
while they're hiding from the hunters.
This seems like the whole group
that next morning,
leaving the office building
where they ran into each other,
they pass through the remains
of one of the buildings
that's been drawn over by a child
with depictions of a fantasy castle
like some child after 23 who was living
here pretended this was a fantasy.
Like, things aren't so bad.
We're living in a castle.
It's protecting us. Everything's
nice outside.
Just to forget the trauma
of how bad things really were.
It's meant to be similar to Sam's drawings
depicting him and his brother Henry,
as if they were superheroes
fighting the federal authority
before the hunters overthrew them.
This is probably just Joe outside,
looking at the hunters in the distance
or their escape route
planning their escape in the game.
It was the Pittsburgh Bridge
that they had to make it across.
The hunters guard every entrance
and exit from the city.
I was in Kansas City this time,
so it's a slightly different exit.
But not only do
they have to avoid the hunters
while making it through the city,
probably couple more encounters.
They also have to distract them
and fight their way through them again
on their way out of the actual city.
Sounds like they're going to be using
the blotter as part of that distraction.
This is just another scene of Ellie
and Sam being kids together
or just having a fun moment quickly
while they rest during their run
from the hunters.
This seems like Henry feeling
as if he's surrendering to the hunters.
Maybe as part of their larger distraction
to actually escape.
Then the action really kicks off
and it seems like Joel tries to help
set off this giant distraction,
like you see a giant explosion
go off in this building,
and then you see the odor escape
with a couple other infected and him
screaming bloody murder at Ella to run
like she's never run before.
Ellie starts
running and firing the gun on the hunters
while she's running,
just like Joel taught her.
And they pay off the scene
from the military tanks
that they turn into, plows
Joe was talking about in episode four,
if you remember, Ellie asked
about all the cars that looked like
they'd been plowed through,
and Joel explained that the military
put giant plows on their tanks
to clear paths through them.
Now, the hunters are doing that,
but in a more sinister way,
trying to plow through them,
Kathleen's voiceover continues,
saying they told her forgiveness,
but thinking forgiveness for Henry,
giving up her brother
to the federal authority and his death
at their hands demands justice.
And for her,
forgiveness does not equal justice.
They just continue some of the themes
of her conversation
with the doctor that she wound up killing.
He was trying to talk her down,
like, look, terrible things happened,
great injustice was visited on
you obviously were very sad
for what happened to your brother.
But this is not the way this has to stop.
Clearly, she does not want to stop it
like I said, it just seems like Joel,
Ellie, Henry and Sam use the floater
as part of their distraction.
Like you see the explosion
go off a bunch of hundreds
in the background with their trucks.
Kathleen's whole tirade on forgiveness is
also meant to be a dark mirror for Joel.
Joel is a character in the game who's
looking for forgiveness and redemption.
He's also learned to forgive
what happened to his daughter
and actually move past it.
He still hasn't fully
come to terms with what happened to her
or what happened to test recently.
That's going to take a long time. He's
working on it.
Ellie is now helping him work
through that pain in the idea
that his relationship with Ellie helps
heal him emotionally over time.
It just takes a long time
for that to happen,
as opposed to Kathleen here,
Melanie Lynskey, whose character
who doesn't care about forgiveness
or redemption
or even dealing with any of her trauma
in a healthy way in early theory,
usually the way things go in
shows like this with arcs like that,
where characters
have like a really dark arc,
it winds up
leading to their gruesome death
maybe at the hands of this blood,
or like Kathleen doesn't care
about laying down arms
or forgiving for anything that happened.
And that's going to wind up
getting her killed.
The big change they made with the blotter
is that the first major encounter
that they had with the blotter in the game
was actually at Bill's inside a school.
The blotters are a future
evolution beyond clickers.
And what happens is the fungus continues
to evolve their bodies.
They just get tougher highs,
they get much bigger
and they gain the ability to throw spore
bombs.
Obviously,
that's a little bit different on the show
because they're not doing spores.
But the idea is
this is meant to be like a super clicker.
So as bad as the clickers were in episode
two, this is going to be way
worse and way harder to kill
if you spot it.
Any of their Easter eggs are references
in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video.
Just write them below in the comments.
My full episode
five video will post Friday after it airs.
Like I said, HBO is releasing it early
because of the Super Bowl.
There will be a ton of Super Bowl
trailers this week and this weekend
I'll try to do videos for everything,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss those.
It'll be fun.
It's going to be a good week
and as a treat, you get an episode
of The Last of US extra early.
Congratulations, Cobra Bear, You're
the giveaway winner from my last video.
Please
email me on the about page of my channels.
We can get your contact details.
Everyone click here for my full Last of us
episode for video
and click here for all my Last of US
episode videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.